good evening I'm Marilyn Quayle
and this little number is one of the
oscar-nominated costumes from the
quintessential movie about colored
people Pleasantville
in that film Judi anima cuffs Keys cool
clothes of the 50s added to the
nostalgic look of a make-believe world
inspired by those memorable
black-and-white television series of
long ago more white than black as I
recall but let's just leave that to [ __ ]
I didn't say whose but you'll be seeing
you know I may not be doing this show
ever again so let's just go right to the
edge and go over what are you saying
so you'll be seeing more of the
nominated costumes throughout the
evening now our next presenter made his
first big splash in a bearskin as Encino
man and had another huge hit in a Lauren
cloth as George of the jungle then he
put some clothes on and broke Ian
McKellen's heart in gods and monsters so
here he is all dressed and ready to go
Brendan Fraser
the concise expression of a story on
film is how many of our writers
producers and directors began their
careers taking short subjects they
learned how to engage us with brevity
clarity and diversity for the best
achievement in live-action short films
the nominees our culture will speckle
and Josh Gordon
election night Val dr. Kim Magnuson and
Anders Thomas Jensen holiday romance
alexander Jovi and JJ Keith Nicole
Stalin the postcard did Janka Fez Viktor
Simon san quest and Joel Berg full and
the Oscar goes to
Kim Magnuson and Anders Thomas Jensen
for election night gaga
Kim Magnuson and Anders Thomas Jensen
have been nominated in this category
three years in a row this is their first
Oscar win
thank you very much thank you to the
Academy thank you everybody who went and
saw the short films more of you have to
go and quickly I want to thank the cast
and crew of this film without them we
couldn't have done it and also on a
personal note I want to thank my family
my mom at home who's taking care of my
kids my beautiful wife my file was
shared there this will and last to some
people over here who helped me out Mac
doc Neil and Missy thank you
to present the next award from a bug's
life Heimlich and flip this thing is so
happy do you remember this thing being
so heavy during rehearsals hey where's
Heimlich I can't wait to taste once they
have it's a Governor's Ball hi we're
here to present the award for best
animated short film because we're
animated and we are short now a small
favor of the winner I realize this is
your big night you know king of the
world and all that and stepping on the
little people is a Hollywood tradition
but please when you come up to accept
your award just watch your step
Thanks and the nominees are
bunny Chris wedge the Canterbury Tales
Christopher grace bones Jonathan myosin
Jolly Roger Mark Baker more mark Osborne
and Steve caliper when life departs
carsten kill Erick and Stefan field mark
and the Oscar goes to Barney Chris wedge
this is the first Academy Award for
Chris wedge who brilliantly worked on
Joe's apartment and Ron
Thank You Fleck Thank You members of the
Academy
this award is especially thrilling
because it's been a labor of love Bunny
for all of us at blue sky studios in New
York for many years actually and so to
my beautiful wife and family jeans heron
jack mom and dad
Nina Rapoport my producer Tom Waits and
Kathleen Brennan for their soulful music
and every one of you that is now where
ever has been a member of Blue Sky
Studios thank you all very much for
helping me follow my heart and for
pouring so much of yours into bunny
thank you
a bug's life wasn't that the Linda Tripp
story anyway
stop encouraging me our next presenter
is an animated feature all by himself
he's been a genie and nanny a loony and
a Jumanji last year he won an Oscar for
playing a shrink in Good Will Hunting
this year he turned a medical-school
upside down in patch Adams
he can't stop playing doctor or with
himself
in addition
he recently stopped hurt in what what
dreams may come
I said that that was right right they've
asked me to be really careful about
pronunciation